and it's going to be eli morgan on the
mound for the indians tonight he will be
the northeast ohio ford dealers indian
starting pitcher
bouncy ball to second base hernandez has
it he'll throw him out
[Applause]
swings and drives one deep center field
back goes zimmer still going back on the
track pulls it down and the tigers go
one two three
and there's the numbers from matt
manning he's in his third start first
start against cleveland fastball at this
point
he bangs it on the ground and beats the
shift
stayed right with it just left it the
other way and with candelario playing
over near shortstop he had no chance
driving a base hit right center field
that's in the gap
cut off by cameron who bobbled it
slightly but stopping at third is cesar
hernandez and the indians have second
and third with nobody out
a line smash on one hop to the second
baseman willie castro tigers will get
the first out the indians will get the
first run
give jose rbi number 45 on the year
he slugs one in the air to center field
plenty deep enough but due will settle
under it
tagging and coming home is ahmed rosario
and the indians lead is two to nothing
[Applause]
miguel cabrera leads off the tigers
second he's the designated hitter
here's a drive
to right center field that is carrying
and that ball's gone
miguel cabrera gets the tigers on the
board with home run number 493
in his career
it's amazing how miguel cambrera
seems to own progressive field
no other player has done
what he's been able to do in cleveland
swinging a miss nice change so eli
morgan works through the inning
back breaking balls he's pitching a
little bit uh
off the charts right field well hit long
run diving attempt by cameron couldn't
come up with it cleanly
harold speeding in the second base goes
in sliding
with a lead off double
that a boy he smokes it into center
field and the indians
go back to a two-run advantage
zimmer's sixth run batted in on the year
3-1 drive here in inning number two
0-1
on the ground nice backhanded play by
harold castro
and they get the lead runner zimmer out
at second base on a heck of a play from
harold castro
tribe leading three to one in the second
here's austin edges
as the high drive hit the deep left
field by austin hedges it is gone to the
home run porch
hedges with his fourth home run of the
year his second against the tigers
it's a big two out two run homer making
it a three run second inning
and the indians lead is now five to one
he put a good swing on it and watch him
around home plate if we see if we keep
it there
look at the eyes
and he knew it with the way the ball is
carrying tonight
he got underneath it there it goes on to
the home run porch
ahmed rosario with another base hit
he took that fastball and wrapped it the
other way
and he's two for two they have to get
over and do
oh nice swing bobby bradley yes sir two
down
he tried to float that little lob pass
over there looked like a tennis shot
but they were selling because they're
selling them
wow that was a perfect pitch by eli
morgan bottom of the zone locked him out
this one to left center field
and it's going to drop between them
rosario and zimmer miscommunication and
cabrera takes advantage
with a sliding two-out double here in
the fourth
his breaking pitch is number two
the two two drop him to left center
field and it does
cabrera scores there we go that's an rbi
single from jamer candelario the tigers
crawl to within three here in cleveland
cuting his thoughts in those answers
right as anyone i've ever heard lead a
team
zimmer swings through it that's the
second strikeout for matt manning
tonight throw their sides oh there's one
on the wrist
i think he says i'm all right trying to
pull away i'm good
their ball smoke deep right field back
is cameron he's out of room it's off the
wall coming around third ernie clement
he will score
a two-out rbi double by cesar hernandez
oh that guy's still telling that story
i'm sure
there's a bouncy ball up the middle
doesn't have eyes it does everybody's
safe hernandez stopping at third
ramirez over two
rip deep right field down the line and
goes goodbye
[Applause]
home run number 17 for jose ramirez and
that indeed is the knockout punch
to matt manning
2-1 to willie castro
there's a hand drive to
rogers pounds one to deep left center
field zimmer goes back he's gonna watch
that fly off the top of the wall i think
it crawled over the yellow line i think
it did too
yep they did they call it a home run
jake rogers fourth of the season
that's a two-run shot
and it's 9-4 cleveland
jake saw a good one on the first pitch
not such a good one on the second pitch
stays over the middle and that launch
angle swing of his right over the top of
the yellow line there hits the railing
you can see that fan actually touched it
over the wall
live driving a base hit
and it got by but do
he didn't realize how hard that ball was
hit it'll be a double for bradley
there's a ball up the middle and big
harrell's got another run batted in
his second hit of the night
rbi number 20 on the ear and the indians
come right back it's 10-4
[Music]
these guys are coming up swinging the
bat get out they wanted to put on a
display
for their teammate
deep center
badou
will make the catch tagging and coming
home is harold ramirez and ernie clement
makes it to third and there are two down
austin hedges with his third one batted
in of the night let me get back in the
rhythm and i'll be fine yeah
i think he's back in his rhythm yeah i'd
say so
chalk it up another extra base hit
speaking of
the rhythm of the night jose ramirez
second straight extra base hit
left center that's in the alley that's
all the way to the wall
jose will score
eddie rosario with his second run batted
in of the night a dirty dozen for the
tribe two on two out and the 2-2 pitch
right field
come on home ernie clement
throw to the play cut off
13-4 jose with his third hit of the
night and his fourth run bad at the end
of the game he could really double
[Music]
with a drive to right and that's gone
robbie grossman with a solo shot here in
the eighth
his tenth of the season
third homer of the night for the tigers
one two pitch swing and a miss he struck
him out to end the game
booking indians up 13-5 tonight they
beat the tigers for the eighth time in
11 meetings